hola mi nombre es luis carlos cortez soy
emprendedor digital desde hace varios
años y quiero compartirles tres
principios clave para cualquier
emprendedor que quiere iniciar su
negocio en internet o si eres una
empresa que quiere es escalar a otras
dimensiones estos principios te pueden
ayudar a llegar mucho más rápido y
seguramente más barato qué tan fácil es
vender un producto un servicio en
internet qué tan fácil es ganar la
partida de los grandes gigantes de la
industria no ya hay mucha gente
haciéndolo no voy tarde ya algunos
pudieran pensar que la era digital y es
cosa del pasado que ya hay muchas
historias de éxito de empresas y
personas que han logrado aprovechar
todas estas tendencias de esta
tecnología para llegar a otras
dimensiones en donde a nosotros nos
encantaría que nuestros emprendimientos
y nuestras marcas estuvieran
aprovechando lo de la misma manera pero
todavía no es así si yo te dijera que el
día de hoy estamos en el mejor momento
para empezar un emprendimiento digital
me lo creería el rápido incremento de la
conectividad de internet ha abierto el
camino a generar una economía digital a
lo largo de todo el mundo es algo sin
fronteras en donde nosotros podemos
comunicarnos y podemos hacer negocio con
gente fuera de nuestra ciudad
fuera de nuestro estado o en otros
países no obstante aún existen grandes
desigualdades hablando de desarrollo de
comercio electrónico existen grandes
desigualdades entre países en vías de
desarrollo y los desarrollados y esto se
debe principalmente a la falta de
competencias digitales que hay entre sí
estoy hablando de conocimientos
habilidades uso de herramientas lecturas
de información entre otras y ahí es
donde empieza la problemática
ahí es donde empezamos a tener falsas
creencias acerca de cómo tener éxito en
esta nueva era digital y de realmente
entender si ya vamos tarde
yo soy emprendedor digital desde hace
varios años y hoy quiero compartirles
tres principios que he aprendido y que
me han ayudado bastante a poder ver esta
gama de oportunidades y sobre todo a
dimensionar todo lo que se puede
alcanzar en este nuevo mundo el primer
principio que quiero compartirles es la
búsqueda constante de nichos potenciales
viendo todo el crecimiento que estamos
viendo en esta industria el poder de los
nichos se vuelve algo muy relevante
porque porque anteriormente las empresas
que buscaban vender escala tienen que
buscar productos masivos productos muy
generales y qué es lo que está
sucediendo hoy en día con las personas
con nosotros
cada día buscamos menos productos
masivos y buscamos cosas mucho más
específicas cosas que vayan más de
acuerdo a nuestros gustos y cosas mucho
más personales es ahí donde el poder de
los dichos también cada día se puede
seguir multiplicando y quiero también
hacer una diferencia cuando hablo de
nichos no estoy hablando de un mercado
meta no estoy hablando de dividir a las
personas por hombre o mujer de tal a tal
edad o de ciertas una cierta zona un
nicho de mercado exclusivamente son
grupos de personas conectadas en la red
sin importar su área geográfica pero que
comparten una pasión y comparten toda
una cultura detrás de un tema y les voy
a poner unos ejemplos por ejemplo las
personas con perry hijos nosotros ya
podemos seguramente ubicar a diferentes
personas que realmente se preocupan y
quieren a sus mascotas a tal grado que
les dan productos orgánicos que los
llevan a espadas hoy en de esta
productos de sb de especializados en
mascotas es impresionante a veces hasta
una envidia la vida que pueden tener
estas mascotas también por ejemplo un
dicho que me encantó es vacaciones
vocacionales hay un gran nicho de
mercado que son personas que están
buscando viajar para trabajar para
aprender habilidades y desarrollar
conocimientos nuevos obviamente la
comunicación hacia ellos tiene que ser
plenamente diferente a que si es una
persona que simplemente quiere descansar
o vacacionar por ejemplo si tú quieres
ser un líder en algún deporte o en
alguna filosofía muy específica a lo
mejor un deporte pongamos de ejemplo el
rugby el rugby en méjico imagínate que
quieras poner una marca que se
especializa en rugby en méjico donde
tengas la mayor variedad de productos la
mejor calidad y que puedas ir agregando
diferentes valores y generar valor
dentro de la marca para que puedas
diferenciarse de los demás personas que
están en la competencia que al final de
cuentas sabemos que en el mundo digital
también va a ser competido el punto
importante aquí a resaltar es esa
diferenciación la clave está en que tú
puedas darle ese valor agregado a los
usuarios a tus nicho que también puede
ser conocido como tribu digital para que
esa persona realmente sepa que tú vas a
saber vas a conocerlo y vas a atender
mucho mejor sus necesidades esta es la
forma en la que podemos competir le a
los grandes gigantes de la industria
porque tú no necesitas robarle clientes
a nadie
tú necesitas identificar estos nichos
necesitas entender cómo funcionan
necesitas hablarles directo para después
cuál es el objetivo el objetivo de
ubicar los nichos es generar
relaciones a largo plazo es generarles
confianza y eso como lo vas a lograr con
el segundo principio el segundo
principio y para esto quiero hacerles
otra pregunta cuántos de ustedes han
visto alguna publicidad en alguna red
social de algún producto o marca que
jamás hayan visto pero en este momento
deciden darles su ipod y comprar
realmente yo sé que son muy pocos porque
no es un comportamiento habitual la
gente no te compra a menos que te
conozca o que tenga alguna referencia de
ti las personas quieren sentirse seguras
al momento de estar realizando alguna
compra y ese es nuestro trabajo nosotros
tenemos que poderles generar esa
confianza y la mejor forma de hacerlo en
la era digital es a través de una
estrategia de contenido el segundo
principio es la generación constante de
contenido de valor y que es contenido de
valor son piezas de contenido diseñadas
y creadas para resolver problemas
específicos de tu nicho cuando tú estás
constantemente buscando ayudar a las
personas a través del contenido qué es
lo que va a pasar si lo haces de manera
constante y de manera gratuita vas a
empezar a generar confianza vas a
empezar a generar empatía y vas a
empezar a convertirte en un líder de
opinión dentro de esa tribu
el objetivo final y eso es lo que te
puede alcanzar a llegar a abrir una gran
gama de oportunidades para después poder
hacer monetizar y poder hacer muchas
cosas distintas algo que me encanta de
este principio del contenido es que a ti
te va a obligar a que tú estés
consumiendo constantemente nuevo
contenido que te estés reinventando que
estés averiguando y actualizando te de
nuevas tendencias y esto es un ciclo
donde al mismo tiempo al tú prepararte
mejor vas a poder ayudar de una mejor
manera a las personas para que después
puedas tú también mejorar tus productos
y tus servicios
así que es un principio que realmente
funciona como un ganar-ganar y me
encanta y otra cosa muy importante
mencionar es el alcance porque hoy en
día nosotros sabemos que podemos llegar
a miles a decenas de miles a millones de
personas a través de una computadora
internet sabemos que es posible porque
hay gente que lo está haciendo muchas
alrededor del mundo y qué es lo que
sucede anteriormente si tú quisieras
convocar a un gran número de personas en
un solo lugar para transmitir un mensaje
tendrías que haber rentado salones
tendrás que ha rentado estadios hoteles
completos algo que para la mayoría de
las personas pues no es costeable
imagínense la más
de la organización que uno debería tener
para juntar ese grupo de personas y hoy
en día lo podemos hacer sentados en
nuestra casa ahí es cuando la dimensión
en el juego cambia completamente de un
mundo tradicional análogo a un mundo
digital en donde las barreras híjole no
existen barreras geográficas y puedes
tener un alcance mucho mayor
voy a darles un ejemplo de este segundo
principio de una empresa que la verdad
es que me encantó como lo aplicaron es
una farmacéutica una de las más grandes
si no es que la más grande de méxico si
tú investigas un poco las cuentas que
tienen en sus redes ellos constantemente
están compartiendo tips están
compartiendo remedios caseros soluciones
a algunos problemas de salud típicos que
puedes ver en cualquier casa ellos han
entendido cómo funciona este juego del
contenido que le interesa a las personas
y también el contenido de poderles
ayudar con algún problema y a lo mejor
algunos ya se podrá preguntar que hace
alguna farmacéutica compartiendo
información de algunos remedios caseros
de cosas que solucionan con sus
productos pero es que ellos
efectivamente ya lo entendieron ya saben
que si generan confianza en los usuarios
y crean esta relación con ellos a largo
plazo en el momento en el que esas
tengan algún problema o necesiten
comprar un producto o un servicio te
puedo asegurar que manera de comprar te
lo a ti porque ya les generas de
confianza porque ya saben que eres un
líder de opinión y ya los has ayudado
porque se irían con otra persona y con
esto entró al tercer principio y para
esto quiero hacerles otra pregunta más
cuántos de ustedes han visto un producto
o les han presentado un proyecto nuevo
que digan este es el negocio millonario
esto nos va a sacar del problema esto va
a ser un hitazo apenas lo saquemos pero
al momento que lo lanza al mercado no se
vende o no tiene esa respuesta que tú
esperabas a mí me hubiera encantado
tener claro ese tercer principio hace
muchos años porque me hubieran ahorrado
un gran dolor de cabeza mucho estrés y
también mucho dinero y el tercer
principio habló de la micro
experimentación la micro experimentación
a mí me gusta a simplificarlo con el
concepto de envipe en vip y bmw producto
mínimo viable es una metodología del
inestur top de eric rise donde te dice
de qué manera tú puedes descubrir
necesidades validar ideas productos
hasta validar modelos de negocio
completos por medio de esta micro
experimentación una ventaja de la
es que tú tienes muy claras todas las
mediciones es muy transparente la
información eso te permite crear micro
experimentación organizada y controlada
que ahí está la clave para que tú puedas
estar en un constante prueba y error ver
cuál va a ser la retroalimentación de la
gente a la que te estás dirigiendo y esa
retroalimentación es la que te va a
decir cuál es el camino al que vas a
llegar cuáles son los más eficientes
según cuál sea tu objetivo lo que me
encanta de este principio es que puedes
aplicarlo a muchas cosas por ejemplo el
contenido en el mejor puedes lanzar dos
piezas en la misma pieza de contenido
con dos títulos distintos en una podría
decir tengo el mejor celular del año y
en otra puedes decir el mejor celular
del año será cierto tu puedes jugar y
variarle con esas cosas lanzarlas al
mismo tiempo y con mediciones muy
transparentes puedes ver cuál tiene una
mejor interacción y luego saber a cuál
le vas a dedicar el tiempo la cual le va
a dedicar tu dinero es algo muy
importante también puedes hacer envíos
con proyectos puede ser en bits con
promociones un 2 por 1 paquete o y mi
favorito es con el tema de productos
porque uno a lo mejor puede pensar que
encontró un producto genial y qué
quieres traerte miles de piezas yo te
diría que antes de comprar miles de
piezas puedes comprando una poca
cantidad primero ve sacarlas al mercado
ve que realmente las puedas desplazar ve
que exista un market fit ve que exista
realmente una rentabilidad para que
puedas hacer un negocio y después de
hacer eso ya puedes pensar en grandes
compras sino créanme te puedes quedar
con un stock varado en un almacén con un
estrés de no poderlo sacar que eso me
gustaría decirles que le pasó al primo
de un amigo pero esa es otra historia
la clave importante con los envites es
que tú tengas claras las las formas de
medir la era digital tiene muchos datos
hay mucha información pero si no dedica
su tiempo a estudiarlo y analizarlo de
nada va a servir la clave de este tercer
principio es muy sencilla es equívoca te
rápido y equivoca te barato para así ya
tú poder saber cuáles son las mejores
decisiones para llevar a tu negocio a lo
que tú estés buscando yo creo
personalmente que uno de los mayores
éxitos de las grandes empresas
tecnológicas que todo el mundo conoce
hoy es que son corto se han convertido
en grandes corporaciones pero
siguen comportándose como startups
porque siguen probando cosas nuevas
porque siguen sacando nuevos productos
al mercado y no en todo han tenido éxito
pero eso no los pernos los detiene de
seguir probando cosas nuevas qué tan
fácil es vender un producto un servicio
en internet qué tan fácil es ganarle a
los grandes gigantes de la industria muy
tarde ya nosotros ya sabemos que todos
los días se crean nuevos nichos dentro
del mercado porque cada uno de nosotros
puede formar parte de varios hay nuevas
tendencias nuevas cosas y cada día hay
más gente conectada a la red ya sabes
que cuando tú decides abarcar uno cuando
quieres dirigirte a uno de ellos tienes
que ser tienes que convertirte en un
líder de opinión tienes que buscar
diferenciarte de los demás que te de esa
bandera o ese estandarte que que sea el
que la gente te siga y ya sabes que con
esta información puedes crear micro
experimentos para que el día de mañana
tú puedas ofrecer productos servicios
suscripciones la gama se vuelve tan
amplia que las oportunidades están hasta
donde tú lo quieras ver quiero terminar
recordándoles que el día del 2019 estaba
en un 2 por ciento lo que representaba
el comercio electrónico hablando en
méxico esto fue previo a la pandemia de
cúbito
se espera según la asociación de
mexicana de ventas online que esto pueda
llegar hasta un 20 por ciento en los
próximos 10 años
ahora les quiero preguntar ya ustedes
estamos en un momento para comenzar
muchas gracias
[Música]